hi-yah I'm Lawrence and I'm actually a
teacher at the University of Applied
Sciences in Amsterdam but that's not
what I'm here to talk to you about today
I'm also volunteer at a refugee code
school called pack your future and well
I can tell you what hack your future is
but it's actually been done better in
this video so I'll show you show you a
short clip
[Music]
haiji future is an initiative it's an
organization that especially for
refugees that come to the Netherlands I
think it's mostly Syria but it's from
other places as well people who have
left their countries involuntarily to
pick up a new skill hopefully so hack
your future teaches them computer
programming web development CSS and HTML
and you learn the basic about it and
then JavaScript of course and help them
to find jobs these are people who had
some unfortunate circumstances perhaps
and are trying to do something good for
themselves and for the world I'm proud
of myself that I could learn it all so
this actually tells you a bit about what
hack your future is but not so much
about why hack your future is so IQ
future was founded by a couple of people
who thought well there's a growing group
of refugees coming to our country and
they'll actually have a lot of trouble
entering the job market because they
won't have the right backgrounds they'll
have some language barriers maybe there
are some discrimination issues going on
so how can we prevent these people from
becoming marginalized in our society so
it it funded hack your future because
they decided well what's what's the best
way to actually empower people and the
best way to get them jobs well one of
the best ways currently is to teach them
what if
skills because there's a lot of demand
for web development skills and it allows
you to go into various different paths
as you all know so we thought well how
can we do that we came up with an idea
of of setting up a volunteer program
where volunteers teach refugees every
Sunday for about four hours we have
interactive sessions with them and then
they spend about 20 hours working on
homework assignments and they hand in
their homework on get up and we interact
with them through slack throughout the
week so they actually have some support
for the whole week we teach some basic
skills first we start off with HTML CSS
because they have virtually no technical
skills coming in and that's like a
really easy way to enter this field and
then we spent nine weeks on the basics
of programming through JavaScript which
I had a lot of pleasure and teaching
them they're super motivated so it goes
a lot faster actually doing with my
students at the University and after at
the end of those six months they work on
a project and they actually develop
something themselves they often choose
to develop something that will benefit
other refugees which is really awesome
and alongside that program we also teach
some seminars on how to conduct yourself
and job interviews how to make a good
LinkedIn profile well you know basic
skills that you might also want and
things that are quite different in in
the Netherlands as opposed to for
instance Syria so yeah that's that's the
way that we that we set it up so what
have we achieved well we have about 55
students that have found jobs at
companies such as KPMG booking.com and
KLM I guess that's the the main thing
that we've achieved but we also have an
an active network of students mentors
and alumni there are 200 people strong
they're all in one select group they
help each other out with anything from
[Music]
finding good companies to apply it
- how to cycle through the snow in the
Netherlands when winter comes and we've
also achieved 100% uptime for the past
two years and honestly who can really
say that about any program we're running
we also have some new chapters in
Copenhagen London Annamma so people have
started copying our projects and
hopefully we've achieved part of at
least a better future so I also have a
quote it's not by Steve Jobs it's
bye-bye jack one of her students he says
that his main takeaways from the program
were to how to think like a programmer
how to work in a team and most
importantly that people can still treat
him for the for the person that he are
he that he is and not the way that he
might be seen which i think is very
important thing for these students
coming to us because as soon as they
enter our doors they they stop being a
refugee and they start being a students
and we just treat them like that and we
don't really talk about their
backgrounds at all we just treat them as
students and we say this is your
homework you have to deliver on it we
will be supportive and try to help you
with any issue but well you have to
deliver so actually the point of this
talk is not to tell you how awesome it
is that I work at this program that I
volunteer or how good this program is I
actually want all of you to start
copying this idea and to set up a hack
your future of your own because I think
it's one of the best ways to empower
people so how can you do that well you
need a couple of ingredients first of a
convenient location it's important that
people can actually reach your your
location and and a lot of these people
will be in camps and they might not have
a lot of money or means of
transportation so it's important that
you find a good location secondly you'll
need some laptops they don't need to be
state-of-the-art actually it's better if
developers don't have
state-of-the-art laptop so they learn
how to develop for for all people you'll
need a program director or better yet a
team of people who are prepared to think
about the hard challenges that you might
face to get everybody together we can
help you bit with with that you'll need
mentors and this seems like it might be
difficult to find people to volunteer
especially on a Sunday as we do but
we've actually found that there is an
abundance of mentors people are really
happy to help there are people from
universities there's people from
companies there's people from well any
place you can think of a lot of people
with diverse backgrounds like to help
out as well so we have a very diverse
group of mentors helping out and
students of course this is the most
important parts might not be as easy as
finding the mentors because you need to
find people that have basic English
skills first that's like that's our
minimum requirement but we also want
them to be very motivated so we actually
have them do a little test before
they're allowed to join our program and
it's about learning a skill on your own
so they have to prove that they can do
that within a certain amount of time and
it's a task that really anybody can
complete as long as they're motivated I
guess a lot of people will ask well how
do you get financial supports you don't
need that much money it's nice if some
companies help out and donate old
laptops it's nice if the municipality
helps out with the rent a bit or get
your location but ultimately this is
definitely something that you can
overcome you'd be surprised at how many
people want to help if you have a good
idea of course you also need a
curriculum this is something that can be
very difficult to set up but we've
already done it for you so I'll show you
a link on our curriculum it's just
something on github it's just a list of
topics that we think is good to talk
about but of course you can set up your
own way of doing it so how would you do
this well just like Jess Kampf you can
just say like well I think this is a
great idea I want to do this in my city
so I'm just gonna basically fork the the
projects which you can do from github
hack your future and then if you want to
know how to get started you can just go
to start code school and there will be
lots of tips there there will be lots of
documents there will be like a setup for
a code of conduct there will be an
article about how to deal with students
who have some trouble with staying in
the country there will be some tips on
how to conduct yourself as a as a
teacher so we've tried to share all the
knowledge that we already have here and
we also have links to all the the
resources that we we use if you need
some more help you can also talk to me
on slack actually I think there should
be a space between Lawrence and iron
Alta which is very Dutch name but if you
if you put that in you should be able to
find me or you can just find me in real
life I'll be around for these two days
and I hope to work together with you
into creating a better future thank you
[Applause]